bonjour à tous le second épisode de law
qui vient de sortir et il est temps d'en
parler dans ce nouveau rendez vous
habituel je pense très sincèrement que
nous ferons tous les épisodes car c'est
une série qui se dépasse elle même et
qui va s'étendre à tout l'univers du mc
eu hélas en plus les choses sérieuses
vont commencer avec l'épisode 3 évident
donc n'hésitez pas à vous abonner et
rejoindre la communauté pour ne rien
louper tout ça vous êtes nombreux à
regarder les vidéos sans être abonné à
la chaîne s'est totalement le moment de
le faire bien que pouvons-nous analyser
et théoriser sur cet épisode
déjà les îlots qui a été confirmée ce
n'est pas une très grande surprise pour
beaucoup puisque des photos avaient
fuité il ya quelques temps déjà mais il
y avait toujours le doute de et si
c'était loki qui a simplement changé
d'apparence
cela ne semble pas être le cas et puis
effectivement le fait de cacher le
visage de la personne
alors qu'on me dit que c'était un autre
lot qui c'était un petit peu dissonant
donc voilà les îlots qui est confirmée
néanmoins là où je m'interroge le plus
c'est sur ses intentions
est elle vraiment si mauvaise que ça
surtout qu'elle est une variante de loki
et l'eau qui n'a pas spécialement un
mauvais fond mais il a toujours un but
on va dire dont la fin justifie les
moyens
l'épisode 1 était très cérébral et nous
a démontré que l'eau qui ne supportait
pas l'idée d'être conditionnés à être le
gars qui sème la destruction et qui
échoue à longueur de temps et c'est ça
le truc le temps et l'histoire est
définie par les thèmes keeper qui ont
stoppé la guerre multi vercel et ont
imposé leur concept de flux
éternel temporel la vidéo de miss
minutes expliquant tout ça résonne comme
une sorte de propagande d'ailleurs où
les gardiens du temps sont encensés sauf
que voilà et 6
eux ils n'étaient pas si bienveillant
que ça cela expliquerait pour moi la
raison des agissements de lady l'eau qui
elle qui n'aime pas se faire appeler
loki mais qui est condamné à être
désigné comme tel même dans la tva cela
reste assez gênant par moments mobius
est considéré comme blaze et la plupart
du temps et maintenant que quelque chose
de nouveau intervient grâce à l'eau qui
il est tout excité
sans oublier la suprématie de rats vos
narines slayer qui applique au doigt et
à l'oeil les ordres d timekeeper et qui
pourtant reste assez énigmatique
énigmatique car elle semble avoir des
secrets cachés
certaines choses et désolé je vais
devoir encore vous saouler avec ça mais
je pense vraiment très sincèrement que
l'eau qui installe tranquillement
l'arrivée de qu'anglo conquérant déjà
parlé de la tva sans kang s'est déjà
ultra bizarre les deux vont de pair
puisque kong souhaite conquérir toutes
les époques toutes les temporalités et
régner sauf qu'évidemment c'est
contraire à la tva
donc ils sont en quelque sorte des
ennemis jurés d'ailleurs il a aussi une
version de lui même quand guy mort tu ce
qui a déjà travaillé à de maintes
reprise avec la tva dans l'histoire de
mme harvey puis évidemment sans oublier
la pseudo relation amoureuse qu'il a
avec ramona une relation qui d'ailleurs
semble s'installer elle aussi
tranquillement via l'épisode 2 puisque
pendant l'entretien avec mobius gravona
semble avoir fait l'acquisition d'une
sorte de boule à neige qu'elle n'avait
pas avant et d'un stylo de l'école
franklin roosevelt 2 artefacts que
mobius eux pensent être des offrandes de
l'analyste secret de ramona et au vu de
la réaction de la juge cela semble être
le cas
sauf que pourquoi garder secret cet
autre analyste haha mobius alors qu'on
est dans une sorte de police
il devrait justement s'entraider et
travailler en équipe ce n'est clairement
pas normal pour moi
d'ailleurs j'avais oublié d'en parler
dans le premier épisode mais les agents
de la tva font face à une technologie
particulière à la fin de l'épisode une
technologie désigné comme venant du
troisième millénaire troisième
millénaire qui est l'époque de quang le
conquérant et là il faut revenir à lady
l'eau qui comme je vous disais dans la
précédente vidéo l'eau qui n'est pas
quelqu'un qui agit généralement seuls
surtout concernant de grands plans et de
grandes ambitions comme celle ci et je
suspectais du coup que le lot qui
variant travaillait pour quand
puisque le personnage de l'eau qui
fonctionne comme ça on a déjà eu
l'exemple avec thanos et surtout car les
dix lots qui a les moyens de voyager à
travers les époques
elle l'a l'équipement et en plus de ça
elle a conscience et connaît la tva et
cette fois ci avec l'épisode 2 et le
détail du troisième millénaire
il y a moyen d'aller encore plus loin
l'équipement du troisième millénaire
appartient à lady l'eau qui l utilisent
pour piéger justement les agents de la
tva et récupérer leurs restaurateurs
sauf que comment elle a pu se procurer
ce si quelqu'un lui a certainement donné
les moyens de piéger les membres de la
tva est le moyen de voyager à travers
les époques et pour lier justement en
véritables intentions de lady loki cette
dernière vient de possiblement lancer
une nouvelle guerre de multiverse
puisque comme expliqué par miss minutes
6-1 nexus franchi la ligne rouge
la réalité va s'effondrer et rien ne
pourra se réinitialise et c'est ce qu'il
s'est passé puisque le flux éternelle a
sauté comme le déclare des agents de la
tva
c'est une manière de s'émanciper du
destin imposé par les timekeeper avec
leurs flux éternel temporel sauf que
dans le fond un seul personnage peut
souhaiter une nouvelle guerre multi
vercel c'est quand un moyen pour lui de
stopper le règne d
anne keeper et donc de diviser et
multiplier les flux temporel pour
imposer sa suprématie à l'avenir il
aurait pu se servir d'eux les îlots qui
en lui faisant miroiter un espoir
d'échapper à son destin
elle qui ne semble pas se sentir bien en
tant que loki pour entamer son plan sans
avoir à se salir les mains pour le
moment il lui aurait donc fourni
l'équipement nécessaire etc
mais bon cela reste ma vision et matteo
rien il se peut totalement que cela ne
soit pas du tout ça néanmoins kang est
destiné à arriver un jour ou l'autre
notamment via ant man 3 je garde aussi
en tête l'idée du quatrième timekeeper
effectivement dans l'univers marvel
un être suprême a créé les timekeeper
pour justement protéger et garder le
flux temporel intacte sauf qu'il en
existait un mystérieux quatrième qui a
été banni par cet être suprême
personnellement je ne pense pas que nous
aurons la présence à l'écran de cet être
suprême qui a créé les time keeper etc
c'est le meilleur moyen de perdre tout
le monde tellement c'est le genre
d'entités hyper complexe à comprendre
néanmoins l'idée du quatrième timekeeper
banny est intéressante puisqu'on ne sait
pas véritablement pourquoi il est banni
et surtout il est banni en egypte en
2005 100 avant j c sans moyens de sortir
de cette époque
ce qui veut dire qu'il est accessible en
quelque sorte par l'eau qui est lady
loki et ce dernier pourrait apporter des
réponses sur les origines de la tva
origine que l'eau qui n'a pas
l'autorisation de connaître soulignant
que quelque chose ait caché pour moi et
on en revient à la propagande les
véritables origines sont cachés mais son
réadapter en vidéo présentée par miss
minutes encensant les timekeeper enfin
voila je pense avoir fait le tour de cet
épisode 2 dans tous les cas nous aurons
forcément un moment
les time keeper devront intervenir
surtout que maintenant le flux temporel
a complètement sauté il va y avoir de
grandes chances de les voir en action
je vais m'arrêter là si cette vidéo vous
a plu n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit
pouce bleus ça m'encourage beaucoup à
laisser un petit commentaire avec vos
idées et vos théories c'est toujours
hyper intéressant de savoir ce que vous
vous avez en tête et puis bien
évidemment à vous abonner à la chaîne
comme je vous disais on va pas mal parlé
de loki et c'est un rendez-vous que
j'aime bien avoir avec vous donc je vous
attends pour les prochains épisodes
et voilà sachez que du lourd arrive
prochainement sur la chaîne allait que
le lionheart soit avec vous c'était
argot rock
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]